that the ultimate objective of our
individual and collective endeavors is
to enrich he was called the king maker
because of his ability to endorse
would-be precedence
his own presidency is seen as the most
successful and stable in recent
philippine history
fidel ramos was a graduate of the west
point military academy in the united
states upon his return he joined the
philippine army and served in the korean
and vietnam wars
ramos was a cousin of former president
ferdinand marcos who appointed him as
head of a joint police and military
agency which was established during the
martial law years in the 1970s
the presidential election of 1986 was
marred by allegations of large-scale
fraud
i came here to
support
ramos defected to the opposition with
then-defence minister juan ponce relay
that led to the revolution of 1986 a
people power uprising that resulted in
the downfall of the marcos leadership by
virtue of the powers vested in me during
corey aquino's presidency ramos served
as her secretary of national defense and
military chief of staff
[Applause]
ramos ran for preston in 1992 and won in
a bitterly contested election
he was a reluctant politician but when
he became one he completely embraced it
including
all the traditional ways that sometimes
affected his own ambitions for the
country
he encouraged the filipino nation to
look beyond its shores
his administration's main thrust was
economic growth and strengthening
liberal democracy he was known for his
philippines 2000 program to turn the
nation into a more industrialized
country
under his administration a peace
agreement with the morrow national
liberation front a muslim separatist
movement was signed in 1996 and he
pursued a comprehensive reform program
which aimed to protect agricultural
communities across the country but he
was widely criticized for his
reinstatement of the death penalty and
his proposal to change the constitution
to shift to a parliamentary government
and in 1998 after serving for six years
ramos stepped down as president
i wrote the book the administrations
that came after him faced corruption
scandals and military coups
he spent the last few years of his life
writing and advocating for an
independent foreign policy in the
philippines
for a country that's seen its share of
instability and political upheaval fidel
ramos's time in office will likely be
remembered as a time of peace and
prosperity